This is such a crucial thing you guys need to understand,
is you don't need to do the entire due diligence.
If at any point it's not checking the boxes,
get out and go to the next city, okay?
And Melissa, really quick, one thing I wanna just mention
is if you are having a hard time finding cities
with adequate search volume and whatever,
adequate search volume, but low-ish population,
then my advice, go and just do a new niche.
And it doesn't mean you're not gonna come back to concrete,
but sometimes you get so in one niche,
you get so exhausted and burned out
that it just defeats the purpose.
So my advice to you, if you're looking at a bunch of cities,
go do fencing, go try tree service, okay?
Go do that and just try that and see what you find
and it's gonna be refreshing
because you're gonna be into a new niche, okay?